how many years did you work on just
short films I did short films in college
of course so that was going back to well
I'll put it this way I've been making
short films since I was a kid with the
old block camcorder that had to be
plugged into the walls but if we're
talking about real films with crews you
know professional or at least
semi-professional I think my first was
in 99 or 2000 I took about a four year
break once I moved to Los Angeles didn't
know anybody didn't have any money so I
needed to put some pieces together and
once I did that that probably was 2005
and I think my last short film to date
at least would have been a fun little
crime action film called sweet madness
which I believe was 2015 so good solid
ten years of just non-student and we're
not talking student films or kid films
like me going out there pulling in
investors and producers pulling the true
together and just getting it done
there's probably good solid ten eleven
years so that four years that you came
here and you weren't making films what
was that light because you you'd planned
making films since you were a kid
go to film school in a really cool town
and and then you come here and
essentially you probably feel like oh
wow now I'm gonna be living what I set
out to do well reality hits as much as I
love the film school again it didn't
prepare you to go into this industry not
Los Angeles I came out in a sense
cold turkey I'd been taught how to load
some mags and I wrote like a short film
script of my senior film class but I
didn't know how to pull the crew
together I didn't know how to produce I
didn't know about permits I didn't know
anything about any of it I knew I had to
learn it though I also didn't have any
money I had to get a job pretty soon you
find yourself working a job or two and
then I tried I was doing that I got some
internships on the side to try to meet
people figure out how the business work
I eventually got a job at a
literary agency representing writers and
directors and so on and so forth
to learn that side of the business I
started to put together my long term
plan at that point I wanted to know who
was who in the town I wanted to know how
contracts worked what was fair what
wasn't fair I wanted to learn how these
people got representation what it took
and it just took time to get these
things in place and while I was doing
these jobs I had access to no gear I
didn't have money to pay for gear I
didn't know people to ask they'd come in
volunteer
I had no press no brand to sell myself
to get people to want to work with me
for nothing so it took a number of years
to get to a place I was like okay I am
as close as I'm going to be I mean I
couldn't wait another 10 years but I'm
as close as I'm going to be to having
the ability to do my first post-college
film and that was around 2005 I just
eventually just pulled the trigger I so
I'm doing it I'll figure out the rest at
some point you just got to go with it
I'm and so I did I made that film for
about seven or eight thousand dollars
that was the last film I shot on actual
film after that everything went digital
and it saved me a tremendous amount of
money but yeah I that's something that
that film students and everything canon
should be aware of in terms of of me I
just didn't know any better I went to a
film school that taught me some amazing
things about the history of film and I'm
so glad I learned it but I came out here
like a baby I didn't know anybody didn't
know anything and had to learn
everything on my own from the ground up
which has proved beneficial to me in the
long run but at first it was challenging
you just had to find your way and just
go with it
you know with film and you could read a
million books but there's no simple a
twosie about how to make it or how to be
a producer or director a writer so I
kind of did it the only way I knew how I
learned how on set and whatever mistakes
I made I learned from them and didn't do
them again
but it it's and everyone's got their own
road that was mine so yeah I had that
little four year pause and once that
pause ended I've been pumping out films
ever since were you working at the
literary agency the entire for you
know what ended up I will know I worked
at the literary agency for about a year
and a half I interned at Paramount I
interned for some other producers in
town I worked at why don't you remember
the name of I worked at the mall I
worked at restaurants I just worked you
got to make your money oh but that
taught me early on one of the most
important lessons which for me I always
knew what I wanted to do there was no
doubt about it and I was prepared for it
to be an uphill battle for the rest of
my life and it has been I mean being a
filmmaker is hard in all the best ways
to me I think everything you really love
and care about it's hard you know it
takes a lot of effort and filmmaking
certainly requires a lot of effort but
as I've been out here in Los Angeles
steadily working away and putting my
pieces in place and kind of figuring out
okay where is this gonna lead me in five
years versus ten years like where do I
want to go and how am I gonna get there
it took a while for me to figure out
exactly what I needed to do but
throughout that journey I saw a lot of
people come out wanting to do the same
they wouldn't make it very long and one
of the most common traits I saw and the
people who didn't make it very long were
those who I don't think fully
appreciated how hard filmmaking is I
think they loved film I don't think they
loved filmmaking
and it's an important difference I think
that if you come out to this town with
stars in your eyes and some of these
things I've written about before which
you might have read some of my articles
but I think if you come out to LA to be
a filmmaker and kind of the preeminent
thought you have is fame and fortune I
think that's a fine motivation to have
but if it's your primary motivation I
think it's going to be disappointing for
you because the odds are of you making
it big are slim to none I think for me
and for most others if you can sit there
and tell yourself that I will I I would
do this for free the rest of my life
working side jobs never gonna make a lot
of money I'm not gonna have a big house
in Beverly Hills I'm not gonna you know
mingle with the Stars if you can tell
yourself that
I would be happy just making stories
small films that maybe will go to some
festivals but that's about it
and you're okay with that as let's say a
worst case scenario that's all you're
ever gonna do and you're okay with that
I think you're on your way that's a very
good place to start if you do achieve
more and you aspire for more I think
that's perfectly fine but to me that's
always been icing on the cake it'll be a
bonus but I think it's your core you
really need to love the process because
it's it's a challenging one and it's not
for everybody did you see anything that
was eye-opening by working with these
writers at the literary agency I mean I
don't know how close she actually got to
the writers maybe you didn't get that
close to them but just in terms of
seeing the ones that because I know
there's writers that are frustrated with
the you know whether they're novelist or
whatever and it's not what they thought
and they have well sure editors can
totally controlling their book and it's
not you know so there's a lot of
similarities I learned a lot of things
working at the agency I think in terms
of your question the most important
thing I took out of it from a strictly
writing and directing standpoint is that
the fight never ends because it is very
very hard to get representation from a
manager standpoint but certainly from an
agency standpoint you pretty much have
to be a moneymaker
to get attention from an agency
sometimes they'll take on someone who
want a big festival because they believe
in them and they see them as a good
investment about what would happen often
is if an agent has say 30 clients and
these are all people who made it they're
talented people they've broken through
from that ocean of people even then you
know maybe the top five clients get time
with the agents and one else gets
ignored for weeks at a time because
they're not the big money they're not
making the big a-list movies with the
hot new director or the established
director they you know made something
that won a big festival Telluride or
whatever it may be or they're a journey
man who's made some movies that have
been successful here and there but
anyways they're people who've made
movies many of which have been released
theatrically they've they've made it
they're still fighting it's gonna be
Rapp unless your Spielberg on his upper
echelon people it's always gonna be a
scrap and I that was something I learned
early on I said oh so these guys they
made I mean they fought the fight and
they emerged from five hundred thousand
other aspiring filmmakers and they made
it and they're still like I need a job
like get me into a room let me pitch
someone pitch my script and whatever it
is so that was interesting to me and I
think both enlightening and I I think
advantageous because again I was already
kind of prepared but it prepared me even
more so to be okay with it to be okay
to never reach a point where I go okay
boy projects are being thrown on my lap
left to right is great that even after
after and Here I am with escape room
came out theatrically world wide opened
up number one in the UK so it did pretty
good it was a small movie but did pretty
good I didn't have agencies colony no
management companies called me know
entertain attorneys called me I'm still
securing my own deals and I'm getting
more and more and better and better
deals but it's not like it opened the
floodgates so there's never like a door
you open where it just it's easy from
here on out and I think a lot of people
would be surprised to hear that
especially filmmakers
you